What I've noticed though
is I was in Portland,
Oregon and there was a whole like
city of homeless people. Yeah. In La,
it's this just
sparklies like Jimmy's on top
of an ice cream, you know,
you gotta go to skid row skid,
you never seen anything like it.
Skim Rosa homeless city.
It's insane.
It's thousands of homeless people
wandering through the streets. They,
they've taken over entire neighborhoods.
Like it is, it is bizarre.
It's bizarre.
We used to film fear factor downtown.
We would a film it at
these abandoned warehouses.
They would rent them out and we'd, you
know, throw people off the roof and shit.
And uh,
we,
there was this one area
where you would go where,
and I'm not exaggerating, there might
be a thousand people on this block,
like a concert just let out.
Like they were having a homeless concert
and they're all just wandering around.
There's needles everywhere and tense
and garbage in the streets and,
and people just shuffling around,
walking back and forth. So there's,
I guess there's some homeless centers,
you know,
where people can go and get food
and things and shelter. You know,
I'm starting to wonder like,
what's wrong with me with you
because I seem to focus on that.
You know, every city I go to I say, wow.
It seems like there's more
and more homeless people
and other people are saying,
oh, let's go to the freedom trail. Let's,
let's look at the beauty of San
Francisco. Look, I shit on the street.
To me that's like unusual.
San Francisco has an app where you could
find where the people are shitting.
They have not jumped through.
Pulled it up before. Yeah.
There's so many people shitting
in San Francisco on the street.
San were like my friend Jake shields get
a photo of this guy taking a shit right
in front of them.
Just shit sprain out of his ass.
Running into the street from
the side of the street. No,
I don't know why and they just
do it in front of everybody.
I don't know why people,
you know who's sick or the person with
the APP or the guy taking a dump. Well,
I think there's a certain open mindedness
that San Francisco has a lot of very
progressive open minded people.
Which is good,
but the problem is it opens the door
for some ridiculous stuff like people
shitting on the street.
There's too many homeless people too.
They're too open minded and to
liberal. Look at that. That's the,
that's the shit map.
That's where all the people are shitting.
That's a dark puddle of shit where so
many people were shitting on the street in
that area and I don't even know how they
cleaned that up. I mean, what do they do?
They scrape it hose a street
down. Is that an extra, is that,
are they creating jobs?
Let's look at it on the positive side.
Maybe those homeless people reminds me
of the parades when they stepped the
horses. There's nothing you could do
either. I mean, what are you going to do?
Are you going to give these
people a place to live?
I'm going to give these people food.
You going to give these people money?
There's, it's not going to
fix their mental illness.
That's what people don't understand
about a lot of these folks.
It's not that they run on bad luck,
that's they're not on bad luck.
They're mentally ill. They have,
their brain's not working correctly.
And if they don't want to be on medication
and they don't have any way to turn,
they don't have anywhere to go.
They're going to stay there and they
don't have anywhere to shit. And you know,
they just want to use this treat.
And I don't know if they could put up
Porta potties and say for homeless folks
only, and what can they do? We're not
going to solve that on the Joe Rogan.
She might. I'm, I'm an
optimistic person. Steve,
you never know. I was thinking
to myself, he just, you know,
it's just shit in your pants.